But let's bump up a level, and talk about what
you might want to use local storage to store. As
I mentioned before, you probably want to use it to
store user settings. But, any data that may be useful
in a different session of your application, is probably useful
to cache in Index DB or local storage. Finally, an
important way to think of this, is any time you
call a network API, you probably want to cache that response,
in index DB or local storage, so you can
get it back later. When you're offline, this can
be particularly useful, because you already have the data
from a previous session cached. In our conference app, for
example. Each of the data models is being loaded
from a JSON file on the server. In the original
incarnation, these files are loaded every time they're needed,
just relying on HTTP caching to minimize the network transfers.
When I initially made an app cache for the conference app,
I just app cached the JSON files, since of course they
need to be there to run the application. However, it would
make more sense to cache the data here in index database,
for a couple of reasons, first, it can do index lookups
so I can have a table for speakers a table for
sessions have them easily cross reference items in each of them.
And make it easier to search for an entry. Secondly, we can
get the structured data directly out of the
database rather than having to [INAUDIBLE] text file each
time. We can then provide a synchronization system, that
occasionally makes network requests, to refresh the data objects.
Or updates on load or when an unrecognized speaker
is found. One final reminder, though. Keep in mind
as you design your application, that if the user
clears their data from the machine, any data stored
locally is going to be deleted. So,
you shouldn't store the only copy of important
data on the client. Local storage is really just intended to be used as a cache.